hey everybody welcome to lab coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we have a
lot to talk about and we have a lot to
do we're going to set up custom routing
for our react.js app so we use next and
next comes built in with its own routing
but we need to do a little bit more than
that and you'll see what I mean as we go
through it but we're going to need to
set up our own server dot J's file and
we're gonna start out with the mark-up
that they give in the next readme file
so you'll be able to follow along if you
know if you check out the github repo
for an XJS it'll be I don't remember
what section it's in but I'll show you
all in a minute so first let me tell you
I don't know if everyone caught my tweet
yesterday but I had a bunch of meetings
and one of the meetings the last one of
the day was about this project that
we're working on so I just want to bring
everybody up to speed on what what was
decided what was was said at the meeting
so I am hopefully soon I was hoping I
get it today but it wasn't really
realistic but I will have access to the
the server where all the content for the
the current main site Franciscan edu is
so I should have access and then my
colleague Brian Sizemore who recently
became our full stack developer will
we'll both have access so we're gonna
check that out
see what's going on because neither one
of us really have any idea how things
are structured so that should give us a
much better idea of what we're dealing
with and then we can go forward with the
best way to handle that data so that's
in the works and we're just waiting on
our accounts we're gonna get as I said
on the react side of things we're gonna
get our routing set up and then we'll
set up some templates for the different
page types that we'll have so they'll
only be a few different let's say like
templates if you were so two templates
and that should make it should make
things pretty simple if you if you were
to look at the file structure but
there's going to be a lot of different
you know combinations of content that
will be possible so the site to the user
is going to look pretty big but we're
gonna try to keep it as simple as
possible in our file structure for our
react project the content management
system will try to keep as simple as
possible as well but there's no way
getting around the fact that there's
going to be a ton of content we oh
another big part of this that I'd like
us all to be thinking about because it's
where I'd like to work on it and
something I've never done before so I
was reading the article recently I'll
bring it up alright so let me see Apollo
I can't remember all the the terminology
okay so Apollo their dev blog so the
Apollo lets you work with graph QL so we
worked with it before I think on our
last project they're talking about what
they call
a gateway graph qo gateway so it seems
like for them this is like a prepackaged
kind of like product right I don't know
that we'll actually use this or that
it's ready for production yet but I read
the article a while ago so I'm not I'm
going a bit from memory here so
basically what it will do is it's gonna
sit between our content management
system so imagine I should like drawing
up a sketch of this hopefully you all
understand let me know if I'm making no
sense here and I need to just show you
like a diagram but basically we have a
content management system our database
over here we have our users way over
here right our client right so the data
is right now what we've been doing is
the data goes from the content
management system through graph QL API
that that's on the content management
system right so we've done over the
WordPress plugin
and it goes right to our react site so
bigos or servers we're running you know
note on the servers and then it goes
directly to the user what I want to do
is to have a server in between so which
would be this graph QL gateway as it's
called in this article from Apollo so
the Gateway would stitch together
different endpoints so that we could
have the WordPress API and then we could
have data from a bunch of other
different places bring them all together
and then piece them together on this
gateway in whatever format we wanted so
that we could make one API call back to
the Gateway and
Quest's resources from multiple sources
right but it'll all come together and be
sent as if it were just from one source
and that gateway won't just stitch them
together it will also cash a lot of the
calls as well so that's what I'd like to
do I think it could simplify things a
lot and really allow us to I mean let's
let's say for example we're using one
system to manage our events and we want
to show the events on our page
well we'll grab the data from the events
through whatever API that this events
thing comes with well what if we switch
to a different system potentially we
would have to go back and change how
we're doing our API calls on our on the
react side of things right right from
our probably from our server js5 or so
I'm depending on how we have it we have
to change it there
well what if instead we had that gateway
we don't have to changed anything in our
react ups all we have to do is just make
sure in the gateway that it's calling to
the right place I think that would we're
adding another piece but I think
ultimately it would simplify things and
that we wouldn't we wouldn't have to
touch our our react application which
will be reproduced you know to be copied
among multiple servers and we'll be
using load balancing so it wouldn't be
just changing it on one I'll be changing
it on all those you know in all those
places I don't know let me know what you
all think if you need more info I guess
I could link let me put the link to the
article in the live chat and now and if
you're watching this later on and you
want the link as well just put something
in the comments and then I'll
put the link in I'm not gonna bother
with if nobody's interested but just let
me know and and you you can read a
little bit about you about how I'm gonna
do this it's not necessary for the
project to work we've done it before you
know where it's worked without that but
I think it would be nice to have so I'm
not gonna say it's it's not on the wish
list you know wish list things are like
stuff that probably is not gonna happen
unless we have a bunch of free time when
does that ever happen right so it's it's
not at that level I would say it's a
little bit more important to me than
than wish list right now so anyway if
anybody's interested in that if you take
a look at the the article and think like
hey I've done that before or or you want
to learn more about it you know let me
know I'd love to to talk to you more
about it and and see if you all think
that that's a good idea or if I'm if I'm
crazy and we don't need anything like
that all right I think I'm talking a lot
at the beginning of this session but I
haven't streamed for a long time so I
need to make sure we're all caught up a
couple of pull requests just fix some
bugs and things so maybe check that out
the number is three full requests this
morning all from Harshit so fixing bugs
updated packages and updated the readme
and are contributing dot MD files so you
can take a look at those if you want
just the last three that have been I've
been been in there I think it's like 25
26 27 something like that for the PR
numbers the last thing I want to say is
this will be my last stream of the week
tomorrow is Thanksgiving here in the
United States so happy Thanksgiving to
everyone that will be celebrating that
so I won't be streaming tomorrow I also
have the next day off which is Friday
and then on Sunday
fly down to Nashville and I have the
November conference on Monday and
Tuesday Wednesday I'll fly back sometime
on Wednesday so I won't stream Wednesday
either so I won't be back until Thursday
so I don't know what the Internet's
gonna be like at the November conference
it would be cool if I could do some sort
of stream or video from there but I
can't guarantee anything and you know
until I see what the Internet's like
maybe I might be able to pull off some
sort of like Instagram livestream video
those usually don't say you don't need
as good a connection to do something
like that it seems like so I know a lot
of you already follow me on Instagram
but if you're on there and you want to
maybe I'll do some like live shots of
the of the conference but whatever I
mean whatever you all think might be
interesting for me to show you at the
conference let me know and I'll do that
also my talk is going to be about my
live streams so I mean my talks pretty
much it's set it's done but if I'd like
to get if I talked really fast and I get
done with my talk early I think it would
be cool to have some stories or like
examples of cool things that have
happened with with the live coding
sessions so I've been going back through
some of the live chats and the comments
and trying to remember some of the cool
things that have happened and I'm just
going to have kind of a list of them
ready to go so that I can share those
with everyone so if you have anything
memorable to say about these streams or
if there's something especially
something you haven't told me before if
they've impacted your life or your
coding in any type of way you know
meaningful or trivial please let me know
and then they said maybe if I have time
I'll bring it up in
in my top and yes so that I love them
that might be kind of cool I thought
people might like to hear like some some
actual stories of from you all from
watching the watching the stream so
anyway enough with the talking I could
see when I talk I usually lose viewers
so let's get into the coding alright we
will just whoops let me switch to the
right view here almost started coding
without showing the code alright so now
you should be able to see the code see
okay
blinky is asking if we're using next
jazz or Gatsby we have switched to next
Jas so we're using next as in the for
the foreseeable future we're using next
maybe well I mean we have time to switch
to something else we got a couple of
months for this project we're still
early on so I'm not saying it's for sure
100% gonna be next but it's looking like
that right now below us if I'm feeling
better I am feeling better I'm not a
hundred percent yet but I'm feeling a
lot better so I think maybe another day
or two I'll be I'll be 100% back to
normal which is glad I was not I did
really didn't want to fly and have to
give a talk at a conference if I was
sick so it doesn't look like it's gonna
happen now this should be good alright
so first thing we need to do is make a
server j/s file and
it will be too many folders open here
all right
this is simplify things alright so we
wants you to add this new file server da
Jas and I'm gonna bring over so right
now I'm just gonna copy and paste what's
in the next Docs so just there example
will definitely want to edit this but we
can go through this now and see see
what's going on so okay let's get rid of
these you don't need these comments
anymore
the part that we're really gonna add it
a lot it's gonna be this part down here
it's been a few months since I've done
this with next and as always I haven't
really done that much with it before the
stream so so we're gonna be going
through this together
alright so
this actually looks a little bit
different than I remember doing it
before but we should still begin well if
you do want to follow along in the next
documentation the section is called
custom server and routing so actually I
think I found some different boilerplate
code that may run better for us
all right so we have to
all right let me let me bring over this
other kid so I we're gonna bring in some
other code that's basically just going
to do some of the other things for us
that we want to do it's going to speed
things up quite a bit so this is
basically the same as we had before but
in addition this has our our caching so
our server-side render caching this
should look familiar if you remember how
we did this on project one I think it
was project one that we did this right
so next does server-side rendering and
in this case what we can do then is
those pages it'll keep the pages the
actual HTML it'll save them in this case
for an hour so that when a request comes
in it doesn't have to redo everything
right it's not rerender everything it
just sends it which is really nice it's
going to be a lot faster right it
doesn't have to make all the same API
calls again to get the data it's there
so you can see it takes I think this is
not a lot of code 70 lines total but you
know it saves a lot of typing that we
have that we've gotten that example code
here okay and what it also has in here
is we're using a few things that we
didn't have before
right so express this LRU cache right so
we're gonna need to make sure that let's
double check what we need to bring in in
terms of packages yeah so I think we
will need to bring in Express and the
LRU cache let's double check our package
JSON
is to see what we have yeah and we don't
have that so first thing we need to do
is bring that in
oops there it is so let's go yarn add
Express and LRU cache
so I did on what was it Monday I did
that kind of like quiet live coding
session on my own channel because I was
still feeling pretty sick let me know
what y'all think about that is that
worth it to do those occasionally was it
really boring was it useful I mean I did
try to explain things a little bit so it
wasn't completely quiet but if you found
it helpful you know I could do some
stuff like that for some of these other
projects that I don't usually stream for
this stream you know let me know so do
work on some other things that I you
know they're just not they're not really
big project so that might be a better
format to to livestream some of that
okay so we have these now so this should
work and okay cool
Blake Blake and rook like this and maybe
do this in the morning yeah that's what
I was thinking maybe in the morning I
can do that and it's not really a lot of
extra work for me I don't make
thumbnails for those videos I just it's
a lot less work to try to set it up I
can just kind of start it and then go
it's it's pretty easy so I like to be a
little bit more professional for the
free code cam channel in my own channel
I don't I don't care as much okay all
right here we go great I was looking for
this part
so I mentioned parameterised routing and
that's so there were two main things
that I wanted it from this custom server
that we really needed you know otherwise
it's like why bother we already have
browning built in it next but the two
things are the server-side caching which
we just looked at and I guess we really
didn't explain it all but we could go
through that and just
minute and then also this parameterize
routing which basically means we could
go here and have if we have a route that
says well it will be Franciscan ddu
/blog and whatever comes after the blog
would be the ID and that will actually
get passed to our component we'll put
we're not going to have a blog in here
but let's just pretend like we are so in
our pages file where that's where
normally the routes would go right every
page would be its own route it's still
gonna be like that but if you go to the
blog page we'll grab that ID and we'll
be able to use that ID to pull in the
right data so think of like how we use
the slugs in our last that bulletin
project to get the the name of the post
that we wanted from graph QL so we'll be
able to pull that data and then fill the
page in with that data so the one page
the blog page so the blood can Honan
will be able to be used for potentially
hundreds of pages depending on how much
content we have and we only need one
component which is awesome so that's
that's what we want and we'll have we
won't just have blogs we'll have you
know all different things I've done this
before where we've had another page for
search and depending on you know what
came after that was essentially your
search query so there's a lot of
different possibilities of what you
could do for now we're going to keep it
simple and we're just gonna have a test
component just to make sure it's working
I'll probably change it from blog cuz
we're not gonna have a blog so I'll have
to just give it a minute and think about
something that we're likely to have
maybe
maybe departments not departments
[Music]
faculty I for sure I'm pretty sure we're
gonna have pages for each faculty member
you know with like a picture and a
little bit of text maybe like links to
some videos we have of them or some
publications that they've they've
written yeah
let's change that now then so we're
gonna call this faculty okay all right
so we're gonna have a component called
faculty it's going to be super basic for
now just to prove our point about what's
going on so quickly and I totally forgot
to start my timer let me do that now so
quickly let's just go through we've gone
through this already so we're fine but
basically what will happen is so we're
rendering through so for each page so if
if we get nothing just the slash right
and that's obviously the homepage that's
still gonna render end XJS but it's
gonna render and cache alright so let's
go through the flow of when a user comes
comes in so user goes to the homepage
Francisca dot edu it calls render and
cache which I believe is down here so
when it calls render in cache we're
gonna check to see if that key already
exists if we already have the key then
see if we have key
it's gonna look so we'll be able to see
we're logging console logging cache hit
right so it's just gonna serve from the
cache if not then it is actually going
to render the page so we're gonna render
the HTML we're gonna render that page
but then we're going to set the cache
key and the HTML so that the next time
we won't rerender so that's it's it's
actually it's pretty simple you know to
go through it all that's our cache right
we're gonna have caching at different
levels we're gonna run a CDN they'll be
caching there we're probably gonna do
caching on the the CMS side of things as
well so the goal is to make things as
fast as possible for the user and to
reduce the load on our servers as much
as possible and caching is gonna be one
way that we do that okay now let's say a
user goes to a page that's faculty slash
and let's just I'll use my name faculty
slash you know jesse libel they would be
directed to well for the users
perspective they would be directed to
that page they'd see my picture and lots
of awesome stuff about me but in the
background what's happening is these
query params to grab the right data
right from our or api's and then that
page will either be rendered if it's not
already in the cache or it will just be
served right from from the cache so
that's about it otherwise if the page is
not the home page and it's not the
faculty page if it's anything else it's
just going to get
handled like a normal page so it'll fall
back to you know is it a page in here if
not do we have a an error page setup I
don't know if we do or not I'm not sure
if we have an error page setup so
basically if it's not a valid route
it'll throw it'll just have a you know a
404 error page we'll try to make it look
as nice as possible or it'll just fall
back on you know this routing where
whatever's in the pages folder will be
there notice though it does not have the
rendering cache setup so I have to see
we may end up trying to set this up
though I think I did set it up that it
would render in cache on all the other
routes as well so I'll have to check on
that I'll check back to a previous
project and see if we set that up or not
okay so that's that's it that's how our
server is gonna work we'll probably end
up adding more to it as as things go on
should trigger a change okay
so let me make sure I have it saved and
let's let's make a faculty component so
let's grab yeah let's just grab Page
jazz page dot J s and
let's make a new file and call this
faculty is so now we're gonna have
faculty Jas and what we're gonna do is
let's go with let's just print out the
ID so
is it this props something Howard we're
setting these I just let me just save
this for now and then I'll just use
react inspector to figure out I can't
remember how we grab the ID for right
now so all right yeah all right so this
should should work
we don't have crazy errors right now so
that's a good sign the fact would be
flashed Jesse what's should work faculty
that's weird
and see
I may have to go back and check to see
what we did in project one yeah let me
bring up I already have github open on
my other screen so let me check on
project one for a second
I really need to upload an icon for our
fus mark on github organization it still
just has the default that it came with
when I when I started it alright so that
was the CI react repo so if anybody was
to fall along that's where I'm at so I
need to check out the pages and our
single event page should work I'll pull
this over on this screen and make this
bigger how did we bring this in before
oh now I remember okay so we were
bringing in our we're bringing in this
way okay
so we're using get initial props which
lets us make API calls and server or
client-side API calls and that's what we
brought in our query query ID okay all
right that makes a lot more sense
okay so let's see
let's just bring
I'm gonna pull this in otherwise
all right let me check my time okay
actually did I yeah I'm gonna stick with
this timer I know I started a bit late
but let me just stick with that all
right let me check the docks for this
just quickly
because I don't want to go through all
of this with API calls right now
it's
all right so I'm checking in the in the
next yes repo under examples the
server-side caching example and I'm
gonna check how they did their blog
component okay good the example it
basically does exactly what I'm trying
to do here so what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna copy their example and let's see
[Music]
with that where's there we go
all right let's do this bring in some of
the markup and let's change this vistas
to lay out okay this props at the all
right so here's what we're getting so
we're still going to use our get initial
props we're just not making any calls
we're just gonna you know return this so
anything that's returned for good
initial props goes into the props for
that component so we can access it at
this props dot ID so what will happen I
mean obvious I'm just gonna leave this
text here even though we know it's not a
blog post but what will happen then is
we should be able to see whatever we
type in after faculty should show up
here and let's make sure it's food I
think I did not grab the rights
and you can grab enough semicolons here
there we go there we go now I have the
right amount
and you take out
this and we're already exporting here
let's go
so I have too many windows up and I'm
trying to find the example code I was
using
I think I found it
it's
all right here's what I'm confused about
how am I going to incorporate this with
roots into this page
alright this it should work
[Music]
yeah that shouldn't work like that all
right
we leave it a shot okay already an
improvement here so that's good now
let's try out no four or four oh you
know what let's restart the server
and actually I'm probably gonna need to
change I'm gonna need to change our how
we start this like I'm forgetting an
important part of this so yeah we're
still getting the 404 because we're not
we're not changing
so we need to bring in
we need to change a little bit about how
we're doing our are starting everything
up so for our dev instead of running
next we're gonna run node server Jas so
that's going to start our server then
from our server from our server then
next is going to start at some point
next is gonna do its thing right we'll
bring it in up here there you saw rap is
next okay yeah so that's where next is
gonna come into play so we're not just
gonna start it automatically it's gonna
start through the throw server digest
oops let's go to our package JSON again
we also have to change our start command
so it's almost the same as our dev
command now but what we need is to set
the environment to production so we have
that node and production and then node
server dodge is so back at our server
das file C it checks to make sure what
the environment is right so we're
there's certain things you don't really
want to do in a development environment
that you would want to do in production
so one of these things is I don't really
care about caching in our development
environment so I think what I've done
before and so if it's not already built
into this example which off to double
check what we'll do is we can disable
the caching if if dev is true
okay and I believe that's all we'll need
to do for this to work so let me duck
make sure I save this I'm gonna save
that and then now we will stop this and
run your and dev again and it should
look a bit different there we go so
[Music]
there we go so we can see we have a
cache hit now so this is my Jessie blog
post right so my free code camp blog
post we can type in anything you want
there so it works
yay all right alright so since we got to
that point and it works I'm just gonna
start our short break which I can't
believe I got it to work that fast I
mean to be honest with you I usually
expect I expect me to mess up more than
I did
alright so that's cool it did work so
let me take my short break now I'll go
through the live chat and see what you
are saying and try to answer any
questions you have and then let's decide
if we want to do something else if we
want to call it a day or what and I do
have a question for you as well let me
ask this question I know I asked some
questions earlier but so to reiterate
the one question if you have anything
cool about this stream some good impact
it's had on your coding or your life or
anything like that or a good experience
you had interacting with people in the
stream or with me please let me know and
I might incorporate it into my talk at
the November conference the second
question I have
is a so there's a recruiter on LinkedIn
that's trying to get me the for this
react contract job so it's like six
months to do this react project I don't
have a lot of details but has anybody
ever gotten any recruiting stuff from
the dark incorporated I don't know if
they're legit or not so let me know if
you ever gotten anything for VR is it a
good deal or what because I wouldn't
mind taking on another project now
especially it's Christmas time it'd be
cool to have a little extra money buy
some stuff for the kids so if it's legit
maybe I'll maybe I'll say yes I did get
I did get an official rate like offer by
email so I'm okay with their the hourly
rate anyway so let's see okay so hey
everybody there's a lot of people saying
hi at the beginning
oh cool asatya said I actually started
learning react after watching your live
sessions that's really cool you know
I've had a few people that that have
said that and I mean reacts already open
source but if it wasn't and it was a
paid product I would definitely try to
get like a commission for everybody
that's hurting to learn it I officially
make no money off of these live streams
any any endorsements I give or it's my
own and I'm not getting paid for it
although if someone wants me to endorse
their product for money let me know
because I might be alright with it
uh-huh Rick says have you used font
ligatures and what do you think of them
okay font ligatures that
sounds familiar to me but I can you
explain a little bit more maybe jog my
memory because I like yeah I need a
little bit more info my answer is
probably going to be I don't know enough
about that to even answer that question
but it's possible that I'm just
forgetting so anyway let me know rug
rook also asked does next you ass get
mixed with react router I think you can
use react router with next I think I
actually looked that up once I can't
remember what I found on it actually
nothing
maybe you can't and yeah don't don't
take this as for sure but I'm I'm pretty
sure when I looked it up the answer was
no you don't use next and react react
router together but like I said I don't
remember for sure what answer I found
and you know maybe there's a way but I
have never used react router and next
together at the same time hey it is here
and it says hey also ask if I'm okay
yeah I'm okay I'm feeling a lot better
I'm not back to back to normal yet but
I'm so much better than I was but so
thank you for asking
AJ AJ EC says yo Jesse what is the free
code can't beta page cold so I can get
old new practice exercises
oh and Blake posted the link in there ok
so hopefully that that link worked for
you oh she Blake reminded me about the N
Groth oh no all right let me start up a
new up right now so sorry so sorry I
even had it I had it on the screen ready
all right let's get this I can't believe
I forgot that I was explaining to people
in the meeting about
project yesterday what n grew up was and
how how we use it and then I just forgot
all right cool the links in the live
chat now so sorry about that really
though I mean it would have been weird
to run it because we had to restart the
servers and everything a few times so we
would have only had to restart once if I
had known what I was doing and hadn't
forgotten to change the this startup
script okay
you know I'm gonna have to check out
that beta version of free code can I I
checked it out a long time ago but I'm
sure it's come so far since then and
Blake even mentions an alpha version of
free code camps lesson so I need to do
that I've always wanted to go through
and finish my free code camp stuff I
just been too busy to do it like
skill-wise alright there's no doubt I
could make it through the rest of the
the front-end portion I mean we do more
complicated things here on the stream
it'd be cool just to get the certificate
you know and I could probably make it
through a lot of the other stuff as well
we'd be going into some uncharted
territory for me but now I'm thinking
should I try or should I just wait and
do the new curriculum so I don't know I
think I might I might wait
we'll see although my life still in the
free code can't curriculum like the
current curriculum right now if she
passes me up I might have to start doing
it again because I can't have her asking
me for help and me not knowing what to
do right it she's actually going pretty
fast through it so she just finished her
well she was working on her weather app
so if any of you done that project I get
you you'll probably remember I know my
timer went off but I only have a few
more things in the live chat so let me
just get through them and then we'll
figure out what we're doing nice okay
look I see that you were giving me the
answer to my issue here with with our
component about setting our you know or
export class and everything so sorry I
didn't look over there I I asked about
it then didn't didn't look at the live
chat so you're entirely right
it's Andrew says hey Jesse I always see
the videos after the live stream cool
sing it live awesome I'm glad that
you're here live with us feel free to
you know say comment or ask questions
and in the live chat let's see
oh cool Brooke said also started to
learn react after watching your last
change it's great awesome
seeing in goose Matt says afternoon
Jessie good afternoon thanks for joining
us and oh cool Blake Blake asks how my
my wife is Rebecca she's the one all
right some of you will know if you've
been watching a live stream you might
know seems to have been having a lot of
health issues over the last year so she
still she was just at the doctor's
yesterday and I gotta go pick up some
medicine for her after this so I don't
know hopefully that the doctors are on
the right track and she'll be she'll be
back to normal but it's been tough it's
been a tough it's been a tough year for
my wife so anyway I appreciate you
asking about her but she really is like
encoding and she's getting excited about
it and she actually met with so the
woman who started and is in charge of
think like women can code Pittsburgh I
think that's what it's called my wife
went up to Pittsburgh to meet with her
today so they had that meeting this
morning I haven't talked to her about it
but that's cool so what was really happy
about that she's getting involved in you
know with coding it was some local
coding group so anyway I'm happy for I'm
really excited and yes and I'm hopeful
about she's gonna be on some new
medication so a couple of the one
medication I'm gonna pick up today and
there's another medication I don't think
will be ready until next week and then
she has to have some more testing done
as well so it's a lot but I have good
health insurance so I'm really happy for
that that's a good the University I work
for does provide good health insurance
compared with other universities that
are our size it's definitely better than
most so anyway yeah so thank you you
know everybody
your concern and so I really appreciate
that and who knows you may be maybe
she'll be doing her own project someday
and I can I could give you guys a link
to her videos how Blake's did you
retweet her on Twitter I think yeah I do
i retweet her yes she thought she really
have like as many followers on Twitter
burn up so I'm trying to get her her
stuff out there and kind of give her
some encouragement when she does coding
stuff and puts it on Twitter so and
that's how she met the she's been
meeting in talking with a lot of other
women who code on on Twitter so so he
has been good for happy dude Rob says
happy day before turkey day yeah
Inga's matt says are you liking next Jay
s better than vanilla react slash create
react app okay so yeah that's a really
good question
so reacts I started the first time I
ever tried to use react I did these
great react app and that was pretty
early on I didn't like it as much then
then I bought a couple of sites with
next jazz and I loved next it was really
cool there were some issues that I found
like somewhat annoying but a lot of them
as I worked with her they updated next
and took care of those issues so that
was it was kind of nice that you know
they were they updated frequently then I
went back and used create react Apple
and some things here on the stream and
then as well in my react nano degree
courses and I really liked it so now
going back to next it's a little weird
for me I'm having to like get used to
the next way of doing things again
so I like both but four different things
so I'll say if I need server-side
rendering
I prefer next but if I don't need to
worry about server-side rendering
I prefer create react app I prefer that
also pairing that with react router and
Redux if necessary I actually like that
better so it just depends on the use
case but they're both really great I
think if you wanted to start out either
way would be fine they're both pretty
easy to use but create rack tap seems
like I said if you don't need
server-side rendering to me it's it's
just a little bit more simple and I like
working with react router and Redux
Redux was a pain to learn but it's
really nice once you kind of get the
hang of it and I'm no expert in redux
but I know enough to build things that
work with it and I really like it
although you probably could use Redux
with next so I don't want to make it
seem like you can't use redux with next
I just have never done it John Hanson
says Jessie got me going on react
learning a lot thanks Jessie you welcome
I didn't realize I had so many people
like learning react that's really cool
Rob says sorry to hear about your wife
hope she gets well soon and thanks Rob
I appreciate it
Dimitar says hi Jesse I'm learning
nodejs
I was into Java spring but-- but now i
am working and learning with nodejs do
you think that I will get on well with
that cheers oh I mean I don't I I think
note is it's pretty easy to learn it I
mean it has been for me and and I'm not
I haven't done a lot with node I'll be a
setup basic servers file upload things
you know handling forms trying to think
you know some really kind of basic stuff
but I don't think it's too hard so I
mean I haven't really worked with you or
senior your work but I think you ought
to do fine if you have experience with
you know with other frameworks or other
languages right Shane like Java spring
boot right I think you'll be fine with
note it's just gonna be concepts should
be somewhat similar syntax will be a
little bit different but no doubt I
think anybody that's learned does a
decent learning in any other type of
programming would be fine to pick up
node and and you know with a little work
you know become good with it
English messes readers confuses me it
confuse me so much at first so much yeah
actually I'm gonna do maybe I'll try to
do it today I really want to do the the
video review of the Udacity nano to
react nano degree
yeah and I want to explain about my
experience learning react in that are
learning Redux in that course so I mean
just a little preview of it there are
three projects you have to do the first
one does not involve Redux the second
one does and the third one Redux is
optional the second project took so much
longer than either of the other projects
because I had to learn Redux and use it
and I ended up using Redux in the third
project but because I had already
learned it it was so easy to implement
but I found project 2 to be so much
harder than project 3 project 3 was with
react native so I don't know how they
can if they manage to be like that or if
there's some way they can try change
things up but normally you would expect
the last project to be the most
difficult but that was not the case for
me and I'm not sure if other people had
a similar experience but that was kind
of the only surprising thing for me was
that the final project just seemed a lot
easier than the read up the Redux
projects okay so I've gotten to the
bottom of the lodge so at this point
let's see there's not a whole lot of
viewers still still around we haven't
been streaming for that long so I'm open
to doing some more but basically we've
done we've completed everything that I
wanted to do for the stream
and we've had a decent question and
answer period um let me let me commit
these I'm gonna commit them while we're
on the stream all these changes so I
don't forget and then if it'll be a nice
example of how to commit your changes
with get let's do a git status and then
I think after that I'm just gonna you
know finish up the stream even though
it's a bit shorter or the video the
normal oops
that is okay so let's see we've added
we've modified package.json you are a
lot which is expected we've added this
faculty dodge ass and we've added server
dodge ass so this is exactly as expected
so let's go ahead and do a get add and
then a dot for all and then we'll do a
git commit and then we'll use an M flag
for message to commit message and let's
say adds add custom server yeah that's
that's a good a decent commit message I
guess so
it's gonna run all the tests now
hopefully I didn't do things that would
break my breaking that's what link is
defined but never used okay
that's an easy one to fix let's just
remove that and I am using all the other
stuff okay let's try it again
I'm a little worried about if it'll pass
all the tests with the server set up
differently
I'm not sure though cuz hardship did all
of the tests so cool it looks like it
works right and we did not write a test
for our faculty page so that's something
that we will need to do you notice we
only tested index and page two so we
need to test for that if anybody likes
writing test you know take a shot out at
otherwise maybe we'll do it in a future
stream and push origin so we're gonna
when we get push we've already set up
our get up repo and of earlier stream so
when we push it's it's going to our repo
and that's our Franciscan react repo the
link to that is in the description if
you're interested in checking it out
alright so I'm gonna check the live chat
just one more time see if there's any
more questions
Vasudev asks hey will there be any
project on angular 2 using MongoDB
I don't know so there's someone else on
the freakin camp channel is is currently
doing an angular videos so they did one
video I don't know how many other videos
are gonna come out so I don't know
what's planned for that so I really I
can't answer that in terms of [ __ ] we
are using our last project it was a
project for I think we're using [ __ ]
for that is that the one yeah I think
that's the one where we're doing some
some user and we have some user
credentials and things and we may be
working more with with [ __ ] in the
future and future streams as well I
can't say for sure though
I'm definitely not working with angular
anytime soon not because I don't like
angular it's just generally for most of
the projects here where I work we use we
use react that wouldn't really make much
sense to throw in an angular project
they'd just be a lot more to learn and
maintain English messes are using mocha
let's see let me let me sure the
package.json here and just you can see
how we have all our tests going so so
yeah so we actually have chai and mocha
and we're using jess so we have unit
tests and we have end-to-end tests so we
have a lot going on here which is
awesome so here's kind of our
dependencies right now and you can check
this out in the repo as well yourself
and then here's how we have our setting
our test set up so we have them
separated out and then you could also
just run tests and it'll do both of them
and then it's it's mixed into our pre
commit so when you go to commit it runs
all the tests as well yeah so if
anybody's interested and if you like if
you you use mocha or just you know or
whatever we're using and you want to you
know contribute I really I'd appreciate
that but I need to get to learn these
more myself so if I need to write some
tests that'll probably be good for me as
well
okay cool one last thing I think I saw
and then we'll wrap things up John
Hanson says all the best at Thanksgiving
to you and your family thanks John
to you you too as well yeah and happy
Thanksgiving to everyone here who will
be celebrating and to those who aren't
have a great week
you probably probably won't hear back
from me and probably won't have a live
stream you know here
all working on this project till
Thursday till next Thursday assuming
that I don't have a million things to do
when I get back I think I'll be able to
stream Thursday afternoon so see you
then otherwise I'll try to put some
stuff up maybe on Instagram and Twitter
from the conference from November I
don't think my talks gonna be live
streams I'm hoping that it will be
recorded and at least put up on YouTube
at some point but if if not then maybe
I'll do turn it into my own YouTube
video at some point and then everyone
can see it
in case you can't come to the conference
all right let me I'm always searching
for the button to stop streaming it's a
big red button and you think it'd be
easier for me to find anyway have a
great week you oh thank you so much for
all your help and Happy Thanksgiving